bonfoh ravaux amadou bah merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
demain ce d'un scrutin sous très haute
sécurité on imagine l'enjeu ce sera
aussi probablement le taux de
participation dans ce contexte
bonjour je vous remercie de m'avoir
invité
je pense que ces élections seront
expliqués mais ce voyageur qui voit se
passe et données
c'est des élections groupées entre eux
mais les six d'attirer les
présidentielles et comme nous le savons
ne puis vous oubliez envahie par les
touristes dans la partie sud-ouest entre
les frontières du mali en plus forte
pour daisy khan est de la centrafrique
maintenant dans la cabine et cinq mois
mais le soufflage et on donne le premier
pas sur le plan sécuritaire sur le plan
sanitaire et sur par région
aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu de taille et
la lutte contre le terrorisme
en seconde il sillonne en jeu qu'ils
respirent économique et développement
parce qu'on ne peut pas développer un
pays non seulement à misant sur la
qualité la sécurité
mais il faut aussi miser sur le
développement économique accompagner ces
jeunes accompagné ces populations ne pas
prendre les contacts sécuritaire tendu
au sahel dans toute la sous région est
ce que demain les nigérians vont aller
voter massivement vous pensez les
nigérians ils sont appelés à voter
massivement
c'est quand même on peut dire qu'il ya
tant de candidats qui ont été validées
par la conventionnelle est le favori et
moi-même besoin qui au nom du sérail ans
élise de l'intérieur et candidat de mon
souffle et les bacs nigérien
démocratique des socialistes qui
aujourd'hui le favori est derrière rinne
où on voit aussi d'autres candidats
qui sort en tête de bol si l'état voilà
alors c'est vrai vous avez cité mohamed
bazoum le un peu le monsieur sécurité du
niger
c'est le dauphin donc annoncé de
mahamadou issoufou qui pour le coup
c'est vrai tient ses promesses ainsi on
doit comparer avec ses voisins lui en
tout cas il n'a pas briguer un troisième
mandat mais il a quand même des il ya un
dauphin donc que faut-il penser de tout
cela est ce qu'il ya véritablement une
alternance démocratique qui s'annonce ou
bien ce sera plutôt la continuité
on peut dire que ce sera une rupture
dans la continuité parce que moi mais
trois ont appliqué une politique
sécuritaire qui a été définie par deux
mois maintenant
donc tout ce qu'il peut faire c'est
appliquer ce qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement mais ce que nous avons
constaté ego si le président mohamed
yusuf a fait un appel récemment pourquoi
débit pour le budget de la maladie non
seulement il va augmenter les forces
militaires mais il va augmenter aussi de
temps pour le budget de l'armée pour
traquer les parrains de matériel pour
lui d'y prendre si tu ne laisseras qui
ont quand même fait quatre morts en 2009
ce qui a été voté
des jolis du personnel qui sont un
concert par coup dans la pique
donc je pense qu'avec mon mail de zoom
un mot quand même sur le climat
politique puisqu'il ya une opposition
d'ailleurs à chaque élection un ou des
opposants exclu de des scrutins c'est le
cas dans les pays voisins on peut citer
en côte d'ivoire laurent gbagbo en
république centrafricaine françois
bozizé puis au niger et à l'ex premier
ministre hama amadou qui lui aussi a été
sa candidature a été rejetée pour une
affaire aussi judiciaire ça veut dire
que le niger ne fait pas de temps
exception que cela quand même oui le
niger abn ne pourrait pas l'exception
parce que nous avons envie un des mes 17
ans et président de l'assemblée
nationale mamadou a été validé par un
cautionnaire parce qu'ils l'ont accusé
de trafic d'enfants
ce qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui même s'il
est allé 2
les dernières élections derrière le
président a suffi cette condamnation a
été confirmée aujourd'hui par à coups
anciaux n'est donc ni d'exclure du
second peut constater c'est qu'il ya
d'autres candidats qui ont dit eva
league et qui aujourd'hui j'ai pu dire
faire jouer la surprise dans ces
élections c'est le cas de l'ancien
président mahamane ousmane que tamara
mais vous soutient effectivement c'est
la deuxième force sur le plan national
c'est la deuxième fausse cultive son
parti donc aujourd'hui si on vous dit
que s'ils appuient les deux expositions
moi ce que j'aimerais juste constater
c'est que moi mais je vous rappeler que
vous aussi n'avoir pas aidé signifie
qu'au niveau de la sous région
aujourd'hui en commande de
l'internationale socialiste is
l'illusion d'une seule arme en co2 pour
un mandat qui arrive aujourd'hui au
palais de niveau 2 aujourd'hui il donne
le bon il est aussi critiquée par
l'opposition que j'évoquais aussi qui a
descendu dans la rue on s'en souvient
c'était il ya plusieurs mois de cela
mais maintenant l'opposition qui
dénoncent aussi une mauvaise gouvernance
un manque de transparence de 2
dans le processus notamment électorale
et l'impuissance du de l'état nigérien a
à faire face à l'insécurité aussi oui
effectivement parce que si on vous aviez
beaucoup d'un président noir aux niveaux
non seulement des opposants qui
déshumanise est accusé de mauvaise
gestion et des clients nous avons de son
fils ce qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui
dimanche ce que les exceptions
merci beaucoup à vous amadou bâ d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé au groupe
afrique
ips l'institut de prospective et de
sécurité en europe